in meiner jugend habe ich mir etwas ganz
bewusst zum grundsatz gemacht erwarte
nicht warum dann kannst du auch nicht
enttäuscht werden
das klingt jetzt vielleicht
pessimistisch aber ich finde dass es
nicht sogar glücklicher gemacht hat
immer wieder werde ich freudig
überrascht und ich bin damit wohl nicht
alleine die meisten menschen scheinen
auch so ähnlich zu denken denn auch
nicht bewusst also erwartet nicht von
diesem video und lasst euch vielleicht
positive belassen
es wird heute ein wenig persönlicher wer
schon lädt herzlich willkommen glücklich
zu sein kritik
was wäre wenn wir wüssten was wir in der
zukunft erleben würden schwierige frage
denn wenn der mensch wusste was mit ihm
geschieht würde er dann nicht ganz
extreme wege einschlagen um vorher
gewagtes zu verändern oder um die zeit
die nicht vorhergesagt wurde
anders also quasi als gegengewicht
möglichst sinnvoll oder auch sinnlos je
nachdem zu nutzen oder gleich zählt der
mensch einfach in eine schockstarre bei
dem durch die vorhersage der freie wille
die freie entfaltung die gestaltung des
eigenen lebens genommen wird die
wissenschaft kennt auf diese frage keine
konkrete antwort aber auf die frage ob
der mensch in die zukunft schauen möchte
oder eben nicht
zitat in der griechischen mythologie
hatte kassandra die tochter des
trojanischen königs die gabe in die
zukunft gehen zu können aber sie war
auch dazu verflucht das niemand ihren
prophezeiungen glauben schenke in
unserer studie haben wir herausgefunden
dass menschen die vergabe die kassandra
berühmt machte er ablehnen und auch
wissen über ihre persönliche zukunft
verzichten würden erklärt gerd
gigerenzer direktor des
forschungsbereichs adaptives verhalten
und kognition am max planck institut für
bildungsforschung aber warum wollen wir
nicht in die zukunft sehen wäre doch
eine einmalige chance warum lehnen wir
es ab zu erfahren was auf uns zukommt
spielt dabei die angst vor negativen
erfahrung oder ereignissen eine rolle
der mensch ein in diesem zusammenhang
direkt angst und negative erfahrung mit
der zukunft zu assoziieren
das ist eigentlich schon seltsam es muss
ja schließlich nicht immer direkt
schlechtes auf einen warten tendenziell
nehmen wir aber dennoch den blick in die
zukunft ab wir wollen einfach keine
informationen über unseren lebensweg
erhalten in der wissenschaft hat die
tendenz noch nicht einmal positives
erfahren zu wollen sogar einen namen den
liberaleren zu deutsch
endlich ignoranz in einer im fachmagazin
psychological review veröffentlichten
studie habe ich dann endlich eine
antwort auf die frage nach dem warum
gefunden
die grenzer zufolge stehe hinter dieser
das bestreben mögliches leid und
bedauern zu umgehen welches das wissen
über die zukunft mit sich bringen könnte
gleichzeitig würde man sich aber auch
die freudige spannung von schönen
erlebnissen erhalten wollen in zahlen
ausgedrückt haben von rund 2000
probanden der studie weckt 80 bis 90
prozent nicht von schlechten und 40 bis
77 prozent nicht von guten
zukunftsprognosen wissen wollen 20 der
2000 testperson hätten wirklich alles
wissen wollen in dieser willentlichen
ignoranz scheint dann auch der hase im
pfeffer zu liegen das hat auch der grund
zu sein warum so viele menschen die
empfohlenen vorhersagen meinen wie
vorgeschriebenen besucher bei wahrsager
was fehlt denn da der fracht wieder fünf
was nein dieses mal nicht
vorsorgeuntersuchungen beim arzt sind
höchst unbeliebt eben wegen der
vielleicht auch geringen gefahr hier
wirklich schlimme nachrichten verhalten
aber zum beispiel durch die dampf
vorsorgeuntersuchung habe ich letztens
gemacht alles gut können viele
todesfälle vermieden werden jeder
fünfzehnte deutsche erkrankt an
darmkrebs
in den meisten fällen hätte das
vermieden werden können mein vater zum
beispiel daran gestorben
das hätte wirklich vermieden werden
können das ist dann wirklich schon
traurig ich habe ja noch einen anderen
verdacht ich vermute ja dass wir zu
tisch und auch intellektuell gar nicht
dazu in der lage wären einen wirklichen
blick in die zukunft zu verarbeiten
die zeit erleben wir aus unserer sicht
als in eine richtung gerichtet aber
vielleicht ist das ja gar nicht der fall
warum können wir uns auf den drei raum
achsen in jeder richtung bewegen aber
nicht auf der zeitachse in der physik
gibt es die hypothese dass sich nationen
rückwärts in der zeit bewegen für uns
absolut unvorstellbar
ich denke dass das gründe hat und wir
uns vor bestimmten wissen schützen weil
wir es gar nicht verarbeiten könnten
main vergeben mehr meint gibt es wenn er
mir hier ein abo aufs auge drückt und
wir dann noch einen auf die glocke lebt
dann verpackt wirklich so mine ach ja
und wollte in die zukunft sehen und
wissen was da passiert ab in die
kommentare damit tiere können darüber
bringen und zwar wissenschaftlich
bewiesen schon wieder mein fach ich kann
übrigens auch in die zukunft sehen
zu diesem thema tiere die die zukunft
sehen können gibt es nämlich demnächst
ein
juli also bis dann bleib dran